[Music]
hello and welcome to marshall matters
with me winston marshall at the
spectator today i'm joined by a friend
constantine kissin he's a comedian
co-host of the trigonometry show podcast
with francis foster
and uh author of the upcoming book uh an
immigrant's love letter to the west and
um
constantin you are uh well firstly
welcome thank you for taking the time to
speak with me no it's great to speak
with winston i always happy to speak you
uh born in russia um moved here a long
time ago i think 1995 and you have
family in ukraine do you have family in
russia i don't know but um uh i i
imagine uh this is a very emotional time
for you um and as uh i can only uh
imagine how how difficult it's been for
you to speak out and yet you have you've
been on unheard question time and
various uh shows as well as your own
speaking uh throughout um
uh
how has your opinion changed over the
course of these 19 days what what's your
journey been do you see things
differently now
uh to to the beginning or uh what what's
changed do you think
yeah well first of all thanks for having
me winston and i appreciate your kind
words i do have family in russia i i'm
you know i've got all sides of
all sort of bits to my family i've got
family in russia my mom's ukrainian my
dad's side is from a different part of
the former soviet union i have lots of
relatives in ukraine so my wife's
ukrainian her family are pro-russian
speakers in ukraine like it's it's it's
a very complicated thing
so i've been trying to give people an
honest view of what's been going on for
the last few weeks um and
has my view changed well i don't know my
view is i don't like the word change in
this case because it kind of presupposes
that things have remained the same and
my view has changed whereas i don't
think that's really what's been going on
what i think has been going on is the
situation has developed over time and
therefore the views i have of it have
changed over time as well um i'm afraid
i my views now uh are very uncomfortable
for me to hold but it is not nonetheless
what i think is going on uh you know the
western media has focused a lot on sort
of the human interest story
you know and showing pictures of
refugees fleeing and destruction and so
on which
i can totally understand and i think
it's good for people here
in the uk and elsewhere in the west to
get a a picture of what's going on in
terms of people's lives and how awful
things are
but in terms of the bigger situation i
don't think we're really getting any
accurate coverage because
sadly you know for all the talk about
how brave ukrainians are which they are
and how wonderfully they're defending
their country which they are and which i
would be doing if i were in their
position
i think they're exactly right to be
defending their home when it's under
attack
i'm afraid the truth militarily seems to
be that
russia is struggling but making progress
anyway uh the capital kiev is about to
be encircled
uh most of the ukrainian army which has
been uh held in the east of the country
is once the encirclement of kiev is
complete and they can complete the line
from the southern uh movement from
crimea and the northern movement from
the chennai of belarus area they will
have the entirety not the entirety but
the bulk of the ukrainian army encircled
they will have kiev encircled
and
from there i'm afraid they're just gonna
proceed to batter ukrainian cities into
the ground until ukraine surrenders so
i'm very concerned about what's
happening i'm also concerned that i
don't know that i i really hope i'm
wrong but i don't see a way out a way to
win for ukraine here because i think
their tactic was to
prolong the conflict long enough for the
west to offer more help and more support
i think it's quite clear now the west
isn't going to do that beyond the level
of what it already has done so
i'm concerned that more lives are going
to be lost more hate is going to be
built up more atrocities will be
committed on both sides
uh and
leave a a resentful atmosphere that will
last for generations now i think it's
unavoidable anyway but i just worry that
the longer the conflict goes on the more
casualties what whether media or
long-term they're going to be
without necessarily changing the outcome
of this war
and what do you think that outcome will
be do you have a
kind of concept
you you've spoken very eloquently uh um
explaining putin's position and in fact
in a way that the mainstream media and
the alternative media seems to be
failing to do a lot of people call him
mad rather than trying to understand
what he wants and um
given that you're sort of projecting
that or
forecasting that that he is going to win
and and probably
very high casualty list on both sides uh
what what do you think the
outcome that he will want when it comes
to a negotiation when it comes to a
partition what does what do you think
that looks like well i don't know that
there will be a partition i think that's
very much up for for for discussion
really i think what it looks like is the
enforcement of russia's initial demands
russia's initial demands were
recognition of crimea as part of russia
uh crimea being the peninsula that
russia annexed in 2014
it means recognition of independence for
the two so-called breakaway republics in
the east
with no doubt the the long-term aim that
they join russia in the long term
and then you come to the other two
points on their list which is what all
this fuss is really about which is what
they call a neutral ukraine
by which they mean going back to a
period of time when
moscow decided who gets to be president
in ukraine and the public government and
a
pro-russian redirection of culture of
media of commentary of society the
forcing out from the public space of
anyone who has a more ukrainian uh
nationalist agenda or nationalist view
or a pro-ukrainian view or is in favor
of ukrainian language being predominant
in ukraine and so on and uh the fourth
point being what they call
denatification which is essentially part
of the same process which is having
pretended that ukraine is run by a bunch
of nazis in order to be able to invade
they then have to get rid of certain
people who who they've claimed the nazis
which is that there is a small minority
of people in ukraine who are genuinely
uh on the far right a very small
minority but for the most part that will
be about reading the structures of power
of people who are opposed to russian
dominance in ukraine
and but you've also spoken uh you've
actually gone further than that and and
said that this would actually just be
the beginning and that and that he'll
look to let's say the other baltic
states which have uh russian uh
large minorities of russian speaking and
culturally russian people there and and
that that will be the next frontier and
uh do you still stand well i i never
quite said this what i said was that is
a possibility and that's why those
countries were desperate to be a nato i
wasn't suggesting vladimir putin was
about to invade the baltic states
although of course he has very good
reason to uh people who want to look at
a political map of eastern europe should
find the kaliningrad region on a map and
they'll see that russia has a piece of
its territory that is disconnected from
the rest of russia and the the two
countries that stand in its way are
latvian and lithuania so there is a
geopolitical reason for him to want to
do that but i would also think that the
reaction from the west
has shocked vladimir putin as it shocked
me frankly i was not expecting as
strong and as coordinated and as united
a response from western countries as
we've seen so i don't think that he
would be
certainly at this point uh even thinking
about that i think in the immediate his
his focus will be on trying to win the
war in ukraine uh or get a win that he
can sell as a win back home
um and uh
well trying to save russia's economy
from the impact of the sanctions which
will really really hurt
i don't think he'd be thinking about
invading further at this point
but of course the geopolitical broader
point i was making is if the west
withdraws and refuses to defend its
boundaries and of course russia has
ambitions to expand further and it would
do
uh one thing i think you have insight
into uh you you've you've said that you
have uh ukrainian family who are
pro-russian now uh last week i spoke to
svyatislav vakaczuk who's the lead
singer of akien eltzi uh ukrainian band
and he said that the 24th of february
was a turning point for ukrainians putin
had a paraphrase now he'd united the
country because now they have a common
enemy a common purpose uh against uh the
the russians now i i don't know if you
agree with his statement there i'd be
curious to know that but i'd also like
to know
what is it
what's the uh the world view of those
pro-russian ukrainians and and also
um
the pro-russian or the pro-war russians
i suppose i don't know if you have
insight there okay well so there's three
questions really there so the first
question uh is is he right to say that
uh the invasion of ukraine by vladimir
putin's forces has solidified
pro-ukrainian sentiment even among
russian speakers and ethnic russians in
ukraine that's definitely the case
that's definitely the case that doesn't
mean that every single russian speaker
or pro-russian ukrainian has changed
their mind there are still some people
holding out so and then the other two
questions you've asked is what is the
view of pro-russian ukrainians
and what is their worldview and then the
third question is what is the view of
the pro-invasion russians and we can
take those one at a time so in terms of
the pro-russian ukrainians largely
it is
a sense so
as you will know given how much you've
studied soviet history people in the
soviet union were essentially treated
like a commodity so you would be shipped
to wherever you were needed or wherever
you were necessary so if you were an
aviation engineer and the soviet union
decided to build an aviation plan in the
ukrainian socialist republic then you
would be sent there and it wasn't like
being sent to another country it was
like being moved from stoke to watford
or whatever do you know what i mean
that's how it would have been perceived
by those people and so imagine that
you've just moved from stoke to watford
and suddenly watford declares
independence
from the country and you are now stuck
in a country which you weren't planning
to live in and this country now moves in
a different direction it starts
encouraging people to speak a language
that is not your language uh it starts
to
you know it becomes an independent
country in in every way and there are
things that are happening there that you
don't like and by the way you simply
don't like the collapse of the country
you were living in because you were very
happy in that country you were wealthy
you were comfortable you had a serious
job and suddenly now that world's
collapse then you have to make a living
for yourself there's a new market
economy in which the job that you used
to do is no longer necessary there's an
awful lot of corruption of a different
type to the one that you were used to in
the soviet union and so on and so on and
so on so it's really a sort of i stop
the world i don't want to get off kind
of position for many people and by the
way i'm not saying that in any sort of
derogatory way if you lived 60 years in
a society that changes overnight the the
discomfort of that and the cognitive
dissonance that comes with that is very
very unpleasant
and so there are some people who feel
that they would just you know victims of
a of a historical misfortune
and here is an opportunity to correct
that they never wanted to be apart from
the greater country of russia they would
never felt ukrainian they were sometimes
so there were people who were just
russian people who ended up living in
this part the the soviet authorities
designated as ukraine they never saw
themselves as part of ukraine they saw
themselves as citizens of the soviet
union but presumably then
it's got to be deeper than that because
they could just move back to russia i
mean i know oh no they don't want to
move back to russia they want russia to
move into this party because they
consider historically culturally exactly
religiously part of the russian world
that's that's the the
the phrase of vladimir putin's view so
there are people the who i'm not saying
their position is right or logically
consistent you just asked me to describe
it and so i am
um
that is their world view that you know
the the the and also you add to that the
sort of humiliation of the collapse of
the soviet union we were these great
power that everyone had to you know they
might not have liked us but at least
they had to reckon with us and suddenly
we live in this small powerless country
called ukraine that that you know is
unstable and economically not as
prosperous as we'd hoped and and it's
not able to punch its way
on the international stage to any sort
of great outcome
so all of those things combined together
with history with religion etc and we
can get into the religious side of it
there are there are a lot of reasons for
a small minority of people in ukraine to
feel uh you know betrayed by by history
be betrayed by the fate by fate
and if if that can be remedied
you know uh they'd be quite happy with
it now how many of those people
are watching ukrainian cities now being
destroyed by russian forces and still
hold that opinion i don't know but there
will be some who are still in in favor
of it and they won't be
are they doing are they signing up to
the the russian
military i guess they can't do that but
i don't i don't imagine so i think in
the breakaway regions there are uh sort
of pro-russian people who are part of
the forces that are fighting against
ukrainian and ukrainians and the
ukrainian army uh from that particular
area in in russia and and this is uh
you'll think i'm insane for citing uh an
rt uh poll and uh that it said that
putin's popularity had gone up 10
throughout the course of the war and
given that it's rt one could be
surprised that they didn't it didn't it
wasn't said to go up a thousand percent
so uh obviously uh we don't i don't
trust the the
that news source but um i it doesn't
seem unrealistic to me that he would
have gone up in popularity he was
already immensely popular um by some
polls there particularly amongst uh
elder generations i've seen one thing
that
uh that
indicates to me that the youth don't
feel the same way i just saw that uh
there's been one and a half million
purchases of vpns to use the internet
because the government are
banning social media all the usual
social media uh
sites so that they can uh maintain uh
you know the propaganda lines and and um
consistent ideology among its population
but that is that implies that there's
pushback uh on uh from from certainly
the youth or a part of the of the
population um
do you do you think it's believable that
the uh putin's gone up in popularity um
well i share your skepticism about the
source of this particular poll
uh but i have no hesitation in believing
its results in this particular instance
uh there's no question that putin's
popularity has gone up
and this is one thing that people in the
west don't seem to understand all you
need to do is spend a few hours watching
russian national television to
understand the mood of the country the
mood of the country is
product of
decades now of
look when i use this term i want people
to be very clear that i'm in no way
suggesting that vladimir putin is adolf
hitler or that he's in any way
you know an anti-semite or has a racial
animus in what he's doing or anything of
the kind there's no evidence for that
and i'm not suggesting that but when i
say that the propaganda levels are at
goebbels
stage
what i mean is how powerful it is how
consistent it is how long it's been
going on what the messaging is like look
the people in russia
are cut off as you say from all sorts of
independent information
and if you watch mainstream russian
television there isn't like a question
time debate where you get a person from
this party and from that party having a
discussion and a disagreement
it is three hours at prime time
television in which there is one message
that is reinforced with very graphic
footage and russian people are being
told that there's a genocide being
committed in eastern ukraine that
ukraine is full of nazis that who are
running the country um there's several
instances now where prisoners of war
russian prisoners of war
are on camera saying i i'm shocked by
what's by being here and what's happened
because i literally thought there would
be swastikas everywhere
that's the level of indoctrination so uh
the country so i'm giving it to you from
the russian perspective now i again i
make it clear
this is what putin put out in his speech
was it two days before he invaded or the
week before
in essence the um
the people believe that narrative and
that long history of of russian
civilization yeah yeah sorry and you've
got to remember as well you know
in one of the things that has happened
in russia since the collapse of the
soviet union in 1991 is that there's
been a loss of power and a loss of
purpose in many people's eyes and
where do you go back to in order to
rekindle your sense of your national
glory and unity and achieving something
great together uh it's world war ii
the russian national myth i'm not saying
it's a myth and it's not entirely true
i'm saying me you know every country has
a national myth of some kind something
you tell yourself to be proud of your
country
and the russian national myth is we
defeated fascism uh and
that that view that point of view
has been present for the last 20 years
since the collapse of the soviet union
to the point where cars and moscow
streets would be driving around with the
words
with bumper stickers which say
mojempaftarit
which means we can do it again and that
is a specific reference to defeating
nazism and defeating hitler so if you
tell russian people on national tv we
are fighting the nazis again
and you tell them that their fellow
russians are being genocided in eastern
ukraine by nazis and and and and it's
not very difficult to get a lot of
people to a position where they support
what's happening and of course if they
are not getting alternative information
if they're not getting other points of
view and many of them are not interested
in getting other points of view because
what they're being told fits very nicely
with the beliefs that they already have
then you get to a position where you are
now where the vast majority of people
for the moment support this war and will
continue to support it
yeah that nazi analogy is so potent now
i remember was it 2018 i think boris
johnson said when he would have been
foreign secretary i think at the time he
said something about russians being like
the nazis i can't remember exactly what
he said but it really upset the russians
because
was it 10 or 15 million russians who
20 million russians died fighting the
nazis so now when you see is it the azov
or the azov battalion or a small group
by comparison with the population of the
country that's perfectly ties into the
russian narrative
and suits this supports this
idea of denuzification well there's a
ukrainian element to this which uh is
sadly unfortunate but true which is
during world war ii
when
stalin expanded the borders of the
soviet union by joining forces with
hitler and annexing half of poland and
latvia estonia lithuania and part of
bukharina as well is he expanded the
borders of what is now ukraine what was
the soviet ukraine onto a piece of
poland
which had a uh
valley it's called in russian which had
a
very small
anti-polish anti-jewish ukrainian
nationalist
essentially fascist
cell
this was a tiny number of people who
wanted independence from poland they
wanted to be free of the soviets and
they happened to be
fascists in the way that they thought in
what they wanted to achieve and when
nazi germany attacked the soviet union
these people tried to work with nazi
germany
in order to to hopefully get
independence for ukraine that's what
that's how they saw it they were
completely unrepresentative of anybody
the entire
activities during the war consisted of
fighting against soviet partisans and
massacring the local polish and jewish
populations
and they eventually most of them ended
up either in several positions vis-a-vis
the nazis or in nazi concentration camps
because what they wanted was to be
independent and the nazis just wanted to
use them for their own purposes so this
is a bit of a historical side but the
reason i'm including it is that
uh the ukrainian authorities in seeking
to cultivate ukrainian national identity
did i think make several mistakes one of
them was to make the leader of this
organization stepan bandera
a
sort of national hero because ukraine a
relatively new and very unstable country
historically didn't have any national
heroes to aspire to it didn't have the
winston churchills and the whatevers and
i think maybe there would have been an
element of sort of rubbing the russia's
nose in this
thing as well
um so there were some mistakes that were
made but to suggest that ukraine is full
of nazis or whatever is of course absurd
but but we should also be honest and say
that there's a sliver of ukrainian
society that is very anti-semitic and in
a very particular part of ukraine
historically isn't even part of what we
now call ukraine um there was that
problem uh there was that problem and
there are a few people who are followers
of that ideology and some of them are
fighting to defend ukraine just like
there are people like that in russia and
if russia came under attack
as someone who was a jewish dark-skinned
kid growing up in moscow i had to be
very careful to avoid hordes of
neo-nazis that were roaming the streets
of moscow in the 90s because these
ideologies have always been popular in
eastern europe
anti-semitism has always been popular
well i say in eastern europe in europe
in general
so this is just a a factor and likewise
if the uk came under attack i think we'd
probably have a few sort of racist ethno
ethno nationalist of which there's a few
still left organizing and trying to
quote defend our country from the evil
enemy that's just what happens and the
people who are responsible for
unleashing these forces are in my
opinion the aggressive invaders who are
putting a country in a position of war
when of course that's the tragedy of war
is the worst element of all societies
come together and they are unleashed
upon each other and upon the country in
which the war is going on
the secretary of state for leaving up
michael gove launched the homes for
ukraine
scheme
which
will be one of three ways ukrainians can
get into the country so
as well as this scheme which which means
that
uh
specific ukrainians would need to be
identified and connected uh with a brit
they would be able to come in to stay in
the home of uh
that brit and that brick will be paid
350 pounds a month
to
look after them as well as that there's
the family connection if any of them
have family connections in the uk they
can come over and then the third way is
sort of other ways which might include
student visas or work visas which
may be existing already do you have an
opinion on whether
the scheme is a good idea if it goes far
enough if it's um
yeah it doesn't go far enough what's
your take on that
uh my take on refugees is usually the
same and it's particularly true here
because i i speak to people who are
fleeing war all the time
in my opinion the the best way to help
refugees particularly in a situation
like this where
the truth is the overwhelming majority
of them will want to come back
when this is over uh the best way and
the most cost effective way is for
people to be looked after in the
countries where largely they are being
looked after now which is the
neighboring countries like uh poland
like slovakia and the polish and
slovakian and other neighboring
countries and people of those countries
have been incredibly incredibly generous
and my view is we should be putting
money and support and charity you know
we on trigonometry raised over 55 000
pounds for various charities that are
doing work on the ground there in my
opinion that's a much better way of
helping people because first of all far
more cost effective
ten thousand pounds in poland goes a lot
further than it does in the uk uh but
also it means that people are not
permanently detached from the place that
they want to come back to
you know it's different in different
situations i imagine i know you you do a
lot of work with hong kong and i imagine
not many of those people are leaving in
order to then come back because they
don't see a future for themselves in in
hong kong that's dominated by china in
the way that it is but in this instance
there will be a lot of ukrainians that
do come back even if the country is sort
of more pro-russian or whatever do you
see what i'm saying so
in my opinion what we should do is
what's best for those people and not
what makes us feel good about us and so
i am not uh i'm not one of these peoples
that the people that thinks that the
british government is atrocious for its
handling of refugees or whatever
refugees are being welcomed in
neighboring countries and our efforts
and our money and our energy and our
charity donations and our other uh
things that we put in place in my
opinion should be directed primarily at
helping people on the ground making sure
that people who are fleeing war and make
it to poland or slovakia whatever have
everything they need there so that we
can support them to be able to return to
their homes once that all of this
craziness is over
there's some important differences to
point out
referring to hong kong is firstly
ukrainian men under the age of 60 are
forbidden from leaving ukraine and
they're encouraged to join the military
there so this is women and children who
are leaving the country
women children are not going to want to
stay here alone they're going to want to
go back to their husbands or i suppose
their husbands will come out and the
second
difference is that in hong kong apart
from a few thousands um and
maybe even a few hundred at the
beginning who fled
quite literally because they'd be put in
in
prison for 10 years plus um most hong
kongers are taking their time they took
months maybe
over a year to consider oh do i want to
make the move to britain it's a longer
move these ukrainians are fleeing
a war zone and there's a good chance i'm
basically agreeing with you but there's
a good chance they're going to want to
go back and they might not be able to go
back specifically to where they were
coming from ukraine but they could go to
another region of ukraine i don't know
i don't know ukraine inter
geopolitics well enough to to know
whether it would make sense for them to
go to a different part of ukraine or if
that's a silly suggestion no no it's not
a silly suggestion it really depends on
what happens let's say let's say
that where they came from gets annexed
by yeah well we don't know if that's
going to happen uh
this is one of the things we didn't
quite touch on but i don't know that a
partition is necessarily how this is
going to end i think vladimir putin
would be quite happy for ukraine to
remain a whole country
potentially but to have complete control
over it through a puppet
structure that's in place so that could
be a possibility we don't know so it
remains to be seen but my point is two
million ukrainians are not going to want
to live in europe a lot of them will
want to come back to their country um
and also the other thing that people
forget is
you know people generally tend to move
to countries with a similar culture they
generally tend to move to countries
where the language is similar or is easy
for them to pick up where there's
already a lot of fellow ukrainians in
this case uh and somewhere like poland
is a much better fit uh there's already
been quite a lot of polish uh or
ukrainian immigration into poland quite
quite ironically to replace a lot of the
polish people who are coming to western
europe to work and that it's been that
shift in place for a long time so look
all i'm saying is i think we've got to
make sure that what we're doing is is
aimed at helping ukrainians as opposed
to helping us alleviate the guilt that
we feel because we can't do anything
about the situation um and that's always
been my focus about helping the people
who need to help getting them out of the
conflict getting them to a safe location
where they can have food they can have
electricity etc uh and that's to me that
where our focus should be and as i say
that's where the money is better spent
as well in my opinion
i'm going to ask what might be quite a
shallow question but you and i both in
the entertainment industry or were and
i wonder whether
you seeing uh musicians actors waving
the blue and yellow ukrainian flag
in solidarity as uh genuinely helpful
and encouraging for ukrainians or
perhaps another example of empty virtue
signaling
than if you i think it's both i think it
is empty virtue signaling because it
just reveals that there's nothing we can
do but on the other hand i know that a
lot of people in ukraine feel genuinely
grateful for the practical support that
britain in particular has given but also
for the moral support so i i haven't put
any flags in my social media handles or
whatever because i just think
i've never been a fan of doing that
but i know that there will be people in
ukraine who appreciate that and are
grateful for that so i i i try not to
have too too strong an opinion on it i
think if if people feel that that
somehow signals something to others
great i try to
i always try to think about taking
actions that help uh rather than
uh signaling things that that make me
feel good again
which you said you you had your
fundraiser you raised fifty thousand
fifty five thousand pounds with your um
uh your co-host uh uh francis and uh can
you tell us a little bit about uh
if people want to donate more
are we still able to do that through you
uh for you guys uh and where's that
money going uh so we picked three
charities one is a polish charity that's
working on the ground uh in poland and a
couple are
uh british and american charities that
do very specific targeted medical uh and
uh mental health support for people who
are fleeing war uh the names of all
three escape me now but um
there are lots of charities doing great
work the british cross uh red not the
british the red cross uh ukraine appeal
and many many others so uh people can
just donate directly to those if you
just google you know reliable charities
ukraine there's plenty to donate to and
these are charities like i say that are
helping people on the ground in the
countries around so um that's to me
really what i would encourage people to
do
uh and all of this talk and signaling
whatever look it's not it doesn't do any
harm but i'm personally not persuaded
that it's it's uh it's important to do
or it's particularly worthwhile yeah
well good on you for taking action and
and doing something about that and uh
it's it's
certainly i i think greatly i'm really a
great admirer of you for doing it um i i
i i wonder whether the i mean i don't
know how far into writing your book you
are but uh an immigrant's love letter to
the west does this tie in does your book
tie into
what we're seeing here a little bit this
this the western uh
lack of self-confidence or um
where we are now
and and how that's playing out now
against
russia is is there any link there where
are you at with the with the book the
book is finished and uh i mean i have
been predicting all of this for for many
years my my central point in the book
essentially is what happens if you have
a clash of civilizations and one of them
believes that diversity is our strength
and the other one believes that strength
is our strength
how is that going to end exactly
and what i've been saying for a long
time is that
we have become
a combination of two separate things the
first of which is we have become
particularly western elites have become
a sort of
self-loathing nihilistic
naval gazing people who want to
hate ourselves for the sins of our
forbearers and focus entirely on how
privileged we are and how evil we are
and how evil our history is and how bad
we are and how much we we must
constantly return for our sins while at
the same time ignoring the fact that
the rest of the world particularly china
russia and other powers don't see the
world like this at all uh they see the
world as a very simple competition for
materials resources power influence etc
and so as the west withdraws into
this internal in introspective naval
gazing uh we will end up in a position
where other big players start to flex
their muscles start to expand start to
challenge the western western dominance
china and russia have been talking about
this for a very long time their main
complaint about the united states is the
united states still acts as the world's
only superpower and what they're saying
is well we're back
so in that situation it's very clear to
me that as the west pulls back or as the
west loses confidence or assertiveness
other players will come and i actually
wrote a forward or a preface to my book
which talks about
this very thing in which i said you know
if we don't deal with the fact that we
are becoming
increasingly ignorant to what's
happening in the rest of the world and
we focus solely on ourselves we are
opening the door to some very very dark
things that are coming and i say it in
terms in the first few words and when i
showed it to a few friends they were
like oh constantin this is so well
written but it's way too melodramatic
so initially i took it out of the book
and when this all happened i was like no
no you guys were wrong and i put her
back in so it's back in there now i take
absolutely no pleasure in in predicting
all of this um because
it's not good you know the entire point
of of the book and immigrants love
letter to the west is to wake people up
to the reality that
you know no civilization lasts forever
no civilization lasts forever no empire
lasts forever no
nothing lasts forever and how long the
western world remains to the beacon of
what i think is the best values we've
found not necessarily purity and it's
this great perfect way of looking at the
world at all we've got many problems in
the west but it is in my opinion
and this is where you know i would annoy
russians and chinese alike uh i do think
our values are better
and unless we
retain that understanding and act
accordingly the world is going to get
very dark very quickly and i take no
pleasure in the fact that this is now
happening
do you have a date for the uh publishing
of the book yeah the book is out on the
july 14th but it is available on
pre-order on amazon already so if you
just search an immigrant letter to the
west you'll find it i look forward to
reading it constantine kissing thank you
so much for your time thanks for having
me winston
[Music]
you